شكراً لك على استضافتي هنا ،
دعني أوضح هذه
الحالة الغامضة لماثيو هيدجز الآن
مع كل ما تم الإبلاغ عنه ،
فأنا أتابع الأخبار مؤخرًا منذ
أن اكتسبت قوتها وتغيرت كل هذه
القصص فجأة إلى حالة
مختلفة.  لقد قلنا هذا في
مؤتمرنا الصحفي ، لدينا عملية
مطبقة في عملية التحقيق ،
حيث تم منحه جميع الحقوق وكان
لديه مترجم طوال الوقت كان
يفهم كل السؤال الذي
طُرح عليه وكان قادرًا على الرد عليه  تم توثيقهم
وكل هذه العملية
من حيث الادعاءات
التي يقولها الآن ردًا على
أن ماثيو الأعمار رجل حر يمكنه أن
يقول ما يحب أن يقوله ولكن في
حالتنا نتعامل مع جميع السجناء بكل
إنصاف.  وفقًا لخسارة URI
والسؤال عما إذا كان لديه محام أم
لا ، قال إنه لم يفعل حتى
نهاية وقت صدور حكم المحكمة ،
فأنت تقول إنه فعل نعم فعل ذلك
وتم تأكيد ذلك  طريقة العملية
هي عندما يتم اتهام شخص ما
بقضية خطيرة
وجريمة مثل التجسس بالتأكيد ،
هناك عملية في بداية
التحقيق حيث يتعين علينا الذهاب والقيام
بجميع نتائج الحقائق لفهم
وكشف كل  المعلومات التي تلقيناها
من خلال بلاغ وفي مرحلة معينة
بمجرد تأكيد هذا التحقيق
واعترف بأنه
سأله المترجم عما إذا كان بإمكانه تحمل
تكاليف المحامي الذي
أكد لنا بوضوح أنه لا يستطيع تحمل تكاليف المحامي
ووفقًا للصفراء ، تم تعيين محام من
قبل حكومة الولاية
للوحدة ، وكان المحامي
هو المدافع عنه خلال جميع
جلسات الاستماع في المحكمة ،
كما قال ماثيو تحوطات إنك طلبت منه أن تطلب منه
الإمارات العربية المتحدة  تصرف
كعميل مزدوج يمكنك أيضًا
تأكيد أنه كان جاسوسًا من وجهة
نظرك وأنك طلبت منه أن يكون عميلاً مزدوجًا
يعمل ضد وزارة الخارجية البريطانية.
هذا ليس صحيحًا
لسبب بسيط حيث يمكن لحكومة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
أن
تفهم متى يتجسس العدو
علينا ولكن عندما يأتي ذلك من حليف
كان ذلك بمثابة صدمة كاملة
للحكومة ولا نرد
بنفس الطريقة التي  لا توجد
أسباب تجعلنا نطلب منه العمل
كعميل مزدوج وهذا خطأ تمامًا
وقد تم رفض ادعاءه
ولا نقبله على الإطلاق. لدينا
علاقة تاريخية قوية بين الاتحاد الأوروبي
وحكومة المملكة المتحدة ونعمل
معهم  وهذا هو السبب في أننا
نحاول طوال الوقت إيجاد حل ودي
لهذا الموقف المحرج
لحكومة المملكة المتحدة